Speaker 1: All right. Let's run through
the latest over the last 24 hours related
to this potentially looming arrest of failed
former President Donald Trump. Starting with
there is a stunning new report from New
York Times reporters Maggie Haberman and
Michael C Bender that Donald Trump is
completely disconnected from reality,
wants to be handcuffed If he is arrested and
seems to see most of this as no big deal and
something that will just galvanize his supporters
in favor of him, which to some degree I think
is true and I will get to it. But the people
around Trump are telling The New York Times,
Trump genuinely doesn't seem to understand the
legal jeopardy that he's in here, because it's
not only one, it's not only two. He is looking at
potentially three or more arrests and indictments
over the next couple of months. The New York Times
article Trump at Mar a Lago Magical Thinking and
a Perp Walk Fixation. Those who have spent
time with Donald Trump in recent days say he
has often appeared significantly disconnected
from the severity of his potential legal woes.
Behind closed doors, Trump has told friends and
associates he welcomes the idea of being paraded
by the authorities before a throng of reporters
and news cameras. He has even mused openly about
whether he should smile for the assembled media,
and he has pondered how the public would react and
is said to have described the potential spectacle
as a fun experience. No one is quite sure whether
his remarks are bravado or genuine resignation
about what lies ahead. If he is truly looking
forward to it, he may be disappointed. And part of
that disappointment, as this paragraph indicates,
is that even though often that perp walk
handcuffed situation happens where law
enforcement walks you by a throng of reporters
and they take pictures of you in handcuffs with
someone like Trump, you would expect that it's
quite plausible that Secret Service would arrange
with the court to do it in a quieter and different
way. But I have to tell you that this is very much
a reflection of Trump's narcissism. There is also
a Guardian article that explains Trump wants to be
handcuffed for his court appearance in the Stormy
Daniels case. People close to the former president
said to be unsure whether he's serious about
wanting to do a perp walk, but he wants to be
handcuffed. He thinks that that would turn things
into a spectacle and that that would be a really,
really great thing, a very common narcissistic
tendency as we've illuminated and enumerated for
you before. Narcissists tend to think that they're
always smart enough, clever enough, smooth enough
to escape consequences for their wrongdoing. So
when if indeed Trump is the narcissist that we and
many believe him to be, and we remember other
elements of this, remember during the Mueller
probe, he wanted to sit down and testify, even
though every single lawyer who got anywhere near
him said, you absolutely do not want to do that.
Lawyers realizing that Trump would just lie and
lying lie because another trait of narcissists
is they're not going to be able to tell that I'm
lying. They're not going to be able to catch me
in a lie. So given that we know that about Trump,
he may realistically be seeing this entire series
of possible arrests and indictments against him,
almost like as a TV show, almost like as an out
of body experience where it's kind of happening
to something else. He's just playing a character
in the entire thing, but he's in control and he's
always going to come out on top. Now, I do think
he is going to come out on top in the sense of
I do believe. That if there is one arrest
and it's the Stormy Daniels case and it's
the weakest of all the possible cases, at least
in the Republican primary, it will help Trump
in the general election if Trump is the nominee.
I believe the arrests are not going to help Trump
The MAGA crowd, and many of Trump's more hardcore
ardent supporters certainly will be galvanized
by what they will see as an unfair, politically
motivated arrest if it happens. So in the primary,
I think Trump will benefit from it, but I think
it's going to hurt him in the general if indeed
he is the nominee. And Trump again, because he's
a narcissist. He has this idea that he'll always
spin it in his favor. And what sources are saying
is he doesn't really have any idea how serious all
of this could be, how expensive all of this could
be, and how damaging it actually could be in a
hypothetical general election where Trump is the
Republican nominee in 2024. This is not stopping
Trump from continuing to send bizarre lawyers
on TV. And that's what I want to look at next